and I knew you and I messaged about this
I've always been a huge booty fan and
he's one of like the guys you know I'd
love to be able to talk with him one day
do you have you ever had any experiences
of boosting that's my guy really
Boosie is my guys see some hardest
worker bras yeah he is bro and he and
I've been out to his house in Atlanta
big [ __ ] mansion [ __ ] go car it's
[ __ ] volleyball football core you
know football will feel like he's a
sports fan and he's just he's a legend
in his in his world you know no means
for us just gangster music and just
having that image he's the last one
really almost really he what he is for
sure for sure
indeed you notice though he was he was
incarcerated whenever they had when he
whenever social media came out so he
didn't wouldn't even on it for like
eight years so then I've concern was up
like his social media is so raw
sometimes yeah he's fearless he's really
you know I I was like bro you need a
reality show yeah he was like yeah sure
you know I was like yeah man like you're
hilarious
and just the concept of him loving his
kids don't say that like yeah he really
loves his kids in that and I said you
need to show the world a different light
you've been through a crazy path yeah
and now it's time to show people who you
truly are and why people love you so
much you know this man has a [ __ ] bash
every year oh yeah giving away free
haircuts give it away clothe you at the
part we need 72 barbers out here he does
not he's fearless
you need this now let's do it I love you
yeah I think it could be the mayor man I
think he could I think he could he gotta
clean up some things he did just come
out with dangerous perfume put this on
your lady
[Laughter]
that dangerous perfume that started
Jackson somewhere Jackson Tennessee is
going now it does get into his promos
well when does he saddest a but it
really though he's the he is the
hardest-working person that I following
social media like it never in Ian's man
and he's trying to always figure out
something yeah you know the man got busi
chips yeah [ __ ] juice everything
boosting dude my friend ISM is in a busi
neck brace dude you know boost is a neck
bracing you press it on the side and
it's like we all got some in the neck
brace even it's got a little thing a
motor in it
have you [ __ ] up a little dance for
you and his mother's a teacher yes
mother's a teacher yes still a teacher
I'm and still the teacher is still you
know in the neighborhood people love ya
my brother has I think maybe done some
yard work or something for them but uh
but yeah he always says the nicest
things about her yeah it's Connie it's
crazy man he's a such a legend though he
is you know and he's a real gangster but
he's really but he's a real gangster
that's the thing that people don't
realize about [ __ ] like [ __ ] got like
30 to 40 mugs around him all the time
and he touched Bootsie some just gonna
happen to him and that's how heroes you
know to me so like and you know that's
amazing yeah like they love him you know
from his neighborhood he's done so much
good things and you know steady doing
good things and so they'll ever love him
man yeah they do
he's one of the last people I see on
social media that is really a hundred
percent Braille no matter if he's wrong
or not to others whatever's is his point
of view that's what it is you know like
he um would he say a couple of like a
year ago he's had some stuff on he's
like man half this television making
these children game
you're putting all this you know
television view and something that's
kind of crazy but it's just it's exactly
who he is yeah it is you know you gotta
love it you know yeah this offends his
comments on doing yeah he came out yeah
I remember him telling me you can't put
[Laughter]
you don't know ya know well years oh man
you don't know where's Nick meal coming
from I I love you boo see I'm just
joking man I mean literally man he's my
favorite person to follow
he's just unprecedented evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one